benvenuti e libertà oggi nuovo video
trova gli slam
oggi dovremmo trovare tutti gli slam
nascosti da graham i due quindi il nonno
a grandissima richiesta è tornato il
nonno che l'hiv dobbiamo trovare in
questa caccia al tesoro
come potete vedere la scatola è vuota
dobbiamo trovare tutti i nuovissimi
skifidol food lime quindi dovremo
trovare tutti e 12 i nuovissimi slime
poi apriremo assieme così vediamo come
sono ma dobbiamo evitare di essere presi
per almeno 5 volte perché abbiamo cinque
vite proprio come con g
se però recuperiamo tutti e 12 gli slam
avremmo vinto la salva in sella piede il
video potete scrivere qua sotto dei
commenti qual è il vostro slime
preferito tra tutti quelli che abbiamo
aperto e anche io vi dirò il mio
preferito sono super curiosa di vedere
come sono
siete pronti avete già preso i pop corn
iniziamo subito a versarli iniziamo a
cercare qua in camera per ora non sento
nessun rumore strano quindi forse gremi
qualche altra parte in genere c'è sempre
qualcosa qua nascosto tra i pupazzi mi
raccomando se anche voi nota si sa
qualcosa
scrivetemi subito nei commenti dove sono
piegati per caso hai mangiato qualche
skifidol slime lo sai che non si
mangiano vero
non c'è niente aspetto momento ma questo
era mimetizzato bellissimo ma ho dovuto
ha trovato il primo flight mourinho ok
appoggiamo lo qua se continuiamo la
ricerca così possiamo aprirne due alla
volta
vediamo se qualche altra pupazzetto
nasconde qualcosa all'altro epifani
abbiamo già trovato due direi che sta
andando molto bene finora questo
[Musica]
ok ce l'abbiamo fatta
ora andiamo a priori 2 slime e dichiara
abbiamo già perso la prima vita ma gli
slam sono ancora qua per fortuna granny
non li ha rubati
per fortuna ok andiamo ad aprirli e
abbiamo ancora quattro vite ma ce la
faremo iniziamo da questo questo è uno
schifo
cotton slime allora dentro la confezione
abbiamo una bustina con le palline e poi
lo slime andiamo mischiarli ecco qua lo
slime è davvero un cotton flime vedete è
il profumo e di arancia pensavo che
profuma se di cioccolato in realtà
profuma di arancia ora andiamo a mettere
le palline sopra ed eccolo cura vedete
sembra un po pralinato con le palline
messo pur profumato ora andiamo ad
aprire l'altro ecco come secondo slide
del packaging super carino andiamo ad
aprirlo in troviamo uno slide giallo che
sembra un po ziggy giallo un pò zitti li
wow che carine rischiamo in questo
profumo di vaniglia
ed eccole qua mischiate allo slam
ovviamente si possono anche togliere se
vuole e questo è il pub l'islam
ok abbiamo già due slam si è pronti a
trovare gli altri
proviamo a uscire dalla camera ora per
l'altro dove il mio aiutante aiutante
[Musica]
berlino sta attaccando cremlino
il co averli e maledizioni devo salvarlo
dai grandi
nel frattempo trovatore altro slide
queste sembrano tipo delle gomme da
masticare
ma ovviamente non si mangiano queste
slime anche se somigliano cibo non si
mangiano frattempo berlin 87
raccogliendo dahlgren è davvero il mio
il mio angelo custode berlino
approfittiamo le giochiamo che strano
c'è troppo silenzio è meglio che ci
sbrighiamo vabbè incredibile ne ho già
trovato tre me ora il problema farà
scappare da qui c'è così tanto silenzio
c'è nessuno guardatela sociale
interruzione non lo vedete le proprie
linee le scale
una porta per un pelo non posso che
riescano ad aprire corte si è trovato a
tre e un capi stock doe per l'altro
ok iniziamo da questa 61 skifidol hybrid
prime sovrapposti bianco e nero con
profumo di biscotti
speriamo tra l'altro io adoro la
combinazione bianco e nero
ci sono delle palline di anche mere
questioni tra in bianco e uno nero caro
qua
che carino a questi sono anche bob lee
infatti scoppiano le bolle che questo
invece ha una consistenza un po più
butter guardate un po ho preparato il
biscotto mettiamo dentro lo slime bianco
e chiudiamo enorme forse più crema che
biscotto ma ovviamente ricordi che
questo è uno slide mostrata mente non si
mangiano questi per troppo carino come
un sito ma ci siamo dimenticati una cosa
e cioè le palline e ora magari andiamo a
mischiarlo tutto
aggiungiamo anche le palline così
vediamo come tv e mettiamo le palline
qua al centro
andiamo a mischiare tutto adesso eccolo
qua e super carino e profuma di biscotto
super morbido qua invece abbiamo uno
skifidol gold khamis line
vediamo un po come allora dentro c'è
questo live arancione tutto per ato e
poi queste palline andiamo a vedere come
sono
questo è bellissimo perché tuccio
luminoso e glitterato enorme questo
slime fine di questo è un po più gamine
rispetto agli altri ecco qua guerra tech
del colore pieno di ditter andiamo a
mettere le perline
[Musica]
guardate che carino sempre lo yogurt con
le palline di cioccolato ed ecco qua il
gol 2 grammi slime andiamo ad aprire ora
questo che il big slime due colori
glossy questa confezione carinissima
abbia un rosa fluo e un blu blu celeste
diciamo i miei colori preferiti
praticamente andiamo ad aprirli col club
si sono decisamente dei flachi slime
ecco qua la stessa consistenza fla figo
augurate che bello che si due colori
assieme sono stupendi e un bellissimo
fluffy rosa e benissimo abbiamo già 5
slime è soggetto che si trova l'altro
slide perché l'abbiamo visto prima
assieme quindi andiamo subito a
prenderlo speriamo che i treni non sia
ancora lì ad aspettarmi
prego il cammino c'è qualcos'altro
[Musica]
niente continuiamo con tono
niente ma aspetto molto perché non ha il
suo cappello la teiera cellophane con
dentro perché mi sembrava strano vederla
senza capelli
eccola di questo ho perso un'altra vita
treni era nascosto in quella stanzetta e
aveva in mano uno slam che sembrava tipo
una sorta di ketchup
ma sono riuscita a prendere 3 slime
quindi ora andiamo ad aprirli e poi
andiamo alla ricerca di grammi per
rubargli lo slime ketchup
iniziamo da questo question crunch line
ti amo fu il colore è una sorta di color
caramello né fishbone sono lo stesso un
po color caramello quindi sapere che
molto è il caramello questo andiamo ad
aprirlo eccolo qua profuma tipo di
nocciola caramelle
andiamo a mettere le palline che
stavolta non è solo metà così le altre
le conservo per degli altri flime si
possono vedere attraverso uno slide
perché trasparente le vedete quindi
questo è questo times super profumato
vediamo ora gli altri ecco quello
skifidol stakes lime anche questo è un
packaging carinissimo allora togliamo
innanzitutto questa parte è qua ci sono
tutte le palline sembrano gli yogurt da
mischiare e invece qua abbiamo uomo
slime marroncino che sembra un po butter
qua abbiamo un altro slime giallo
glitterato messo profuma tipo di
nocciola di cioccolato è proprio un
pattern molto e sta immobile mettiamo un
po di quest live giallo sopra e poi come
decorazione finale mettiamo le palline
guardate che carino è bellissimo
andiamo ad aprire ora il cran cheetos
slime è troppo carino questo pack asini
buoi norme rosso sia un grammy smani
trasparente questo e poi abbiamo i ball
gialli wisla in rosso super allungabile
dada bellissimo questo colore
diamo ammettetelo tispol sopra
[Musica]
ecco qua devo dire che giallorossi
stanno benissimo a sieve supercar in i
ragazzi ci mancano solo quattro slime
forse ce la facciamo
comunque non abbiamo guardato molto bene
qua in cameretta perché ne abbiamo
trovato due qua ma forse se non nasconde
qualcun'altro controlliamo meglio
guardate questo si nascondeva qua dietro
perché rosa quindi si mimetizzava questo
è uno smooth slargo delle palline dentro
immagini continuiamo a cercare allora
prima non ho controllato niente
abbiamo controllato guardate che carino
con sé uno squeeze superflash cisl l'msr
expo maionese o mostarda super carino
iniziamo da questo smooth slime sembra
tipo 1 milione tra l'altro pescarini
queste perline che adoro perché sono
tutte color pastello e adoro questi
colori infatti un po le conservo così le
posso usare su altri slime queste le
userò in questo slide
eccolo qua super carino proprio classi e
mettiamo ora le perline colorate sopra
carinissimo andiamo ora ad aprire lo
scrive lo skifidol slime superflop
questo packaging è carinissimo il tappo
uk cerchiamo di farlo uscire
direttamente dalla confezione fare bolle
eccolo qua è enorme è un fluffy anche
questo super morbida o super estendibile
il profumo sadi
io non sono molto brava a riconoscere i
profumi sembra il money e forse o
mostarda possiamo stare da o forse
maionese
non lo so se voi lo avete preso scrivete
nei commenti secondo voi di che cosa sa
questo profumo ed eccolo qua un super
flat pc mancano solo due slime e avremmo
vinto la challenge sempre se non veniamo
presi dai programmi inoltre volte
andiamo subito di là nel corridoio
perché mi che abbiamo visto gli altri
strike
speriamo che i gremi sia andato via ha
chiaro
ai quali non si vantava e l'altro
no
c'è uno chiare
[Musica]
questo ce l'abbiamo fatta più bello c'è
mancato poco
ora un primo subito questi drive
gli ultimi due andiamo ad aprire questo
gelli slime che la bottiglietta la
confezione sembra tipo che il soft
allora vediamo un po come questo con
questo è decisamente più gelli rispetto
agli altri è profuma di ciliegia tipo
pogelli water più sentite fuori andiamo
ad aprire il nostro ultimo slide
purtroppo perché mi stavo divertendo
troppo questo e lo skiff turn off la fim
lime sembrati pure cartoncino dell'abate
andiamo ad aprirlo d'acqua così non
roviniamo la confezione
una slide rosa fu bellissimo i consessi
super carini poi lo slime bianco sembra
che facciano tipo il donut proviamo ad
aprirli e mischiarli suo profumo tipo di
vaniglia e molto delicato e profumo allo
stesso mi sembra proprio che profumi di
donut o di vaniglia allora sto facendo
una sorta di donato scusa se fai un po
storto perché lo sta facendo e super
velocemente comunque quando il nostro
donut andiamo a mettere sopra se mi sono
cadute moltio che carina non le voglio
mettere tutti perché un po le voglio
conservare perché sono troppo belle
queste ferlin anche questo decisamente è
uno dei miei preferiti e troppo carino
proviamo a mischiarlo di un po casa ecco
qua io penso che sia bellissimo questo
adoro questi colori abbiamo vinto la
challenge allora i miei tre preferiti
sono questo che abbiamo appena visto poi
lo squeeze line super fluffy questo
giallo enorme fluffy e poi mi è piaciuto
tantissimo anche questo bug e questo
blitz live tv devi nei commenti quali
sono i vostri preferiti e lasciate un
bel mi piace però avere delle nuove
challenge vi ricordo che potete trovare
i nuovi skifidol food slimer in edicola
in allegato al magazine e ora vi lascio
qua 4 caselline su cui applicare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao
[Musica]